yes you're now live chair
okay uh good morning members and welcome
to anybody
uh watching on youtube i hope you find
the meeting informative
and enjoyable
right can we have apologies for absence
please
thank you chair apologies received from
councillor rossi
right thank you uh right we'll move on
to the
uh minutes of the stanley committee
meeting of the 26th of
august that's pages three to six
attached to your agenda um do we
do you want me to go through them page
by page are members happy with them
i'll move a minutes chair a second
thank you can we go to the vote there
please
thank you chair councillor brenton or
mr clark is that mr clark or councillor
clark
mr clark
come on just a second
you're muted mr clark
there you go you're on muted now am i
muted thank you
yeah you're muted yeah um i'm not a
voting member
is it councillor clark or
councillor ford uh four but i'm happy
being called lenny
councillor hawkins paul
councillor inch not present
counselor laws are full
thank you and then mr rule he's not
present
okay so that's unanimous chair thank you
right uh item three declarations of
interest
members with interest to declare should
refer to the agenda item
and describe the nature of their
interests when the item is being
considered
right and for agreement between
part one and part two we do have a part
two
item today so uh could i have a proposal
or i'll propose from the chair i'll
second councillor clark
thank you can we go to the vote again
please
thank you chair councillor brenton four
councillor clark or councillor ford
or councillor hawkins
councillor hawkins uh four
thank you uh councillor laws oh
thank you that's unanimous thank you
um five urgent matters of information to
be brought forward by
permission of the chair of the committee
does anybody have any matters they wish
to raise at this time
right let's move on to the the meaty bit
uh six best practice uh stacy would you
like to just
introduce us to this
yes jeff thank you um so it's a the
list of best practice that's been issued
by
the committee on standards in public
life
is attached at pages nine to ten
um i can run through them individually
uh some of it's within our um
code of conduct currently and the rest
is is really
whether members would like that included
within our our code of conduct
um now that we've just reviewed the
constitution
it may be that standards committee would
also like to review the members code of
conduct as well
um but i'll leave that that that with
you for consideration
um the last time we updated and reviewed
was august
2018 so it probably is time to
to have a relook at it and see if
if members want to update it um the
government
were talking about amending and having a
general
um code for councils that that hasn't
come through yet so
um we it might be prudent to
amend our own or review our own at the
very least and see what members think
stacy can i just interrupt i think
councillor brenton would like to speak
uh thank you chair i just wondered if
stacy when she goes through the list
could
identify the ones that aren't included
with our present
um codes of conduct because they're not
they're not
identified on there i mean they are as
usual you know
suitably vaguely worded so uh but
nonetheless it would be nice to know
which ones are
not there thank you thank you stacy
certainly so the best practice one um
local authorities should include
prohibitions on bullying and harassment
in codes of conduct
that that's within our code of conduct
already under the general provisions
at 0.2 it says you must not bully or
attempt
authority or intimidate or attempt to
bully or intimidate another person so
that that's
quite clear already
but they're also suggesting that we have
a list of examples of the sort of
behavior that should be covered by that
definition
um that's quite difficult um i think
what members views are is quite
subjective um as to what one person
would
um think is bullying or another but
there is a legal definition that we can
put in there members were minded
to do so or just keep it as it currently
is
yes i mean there are two types of
two distinctive types of bullying
um there's the bullying between members
but then there's also the possibility of
bullying of
officers which is very very serious
do we make any reference to either of
those two specifically within our
guidelines stacy no we just say against
any person
so i suppose it's a catch-all provision
right
um
are members happy with that
chair all i would say is is that um
bullying would normally be something
that's done more than once
it would be a consistent pattern of
behavior um i think it's
i think it's difficult to be certain
that
it's an issue of bullying if it's one
particular event it has to be sustained
in my view
for it to be bullying now whether we can
put that as a definition
that's for others to decide right
well it is covered at the moment
we've got plenty of time to think on
this because
they seem to think that we've covered
they're going to put this back till next
autumn before they
um finalize it so if members don't have
any other thoughts should we move on to
two
stacy chair if i could just before you
move on
um i think i i disagree i do think that
bullying can be just one incident
especially if it's quite a dramatic one
it can it can be just one incident of
where one person
asserts their authority or think that
they got authority over another person
and intimidate them so especially as
there's been cases in the past where a
member has threatened
uh an officer with their job you only
need to say that once
yeah yeah going to be terribly difficult
if you go into specifics um
it is what it is if it's included
uh in a simple form it leaves it open
for um members or officers to make a
complaint
if they feel that they have been and
each case will just have to be looked at
individually would you uh
agree with that stacy yesterday
right right
uh councillor hawkins please
oh yeah good morning i don't know if you
recall actually uh
council laws i did send you what we
didn't before they complained about this
but it was an incident that happened
about six months ago um
whether anybody could clarify what what
the procedure would be
for example if i were to witness
something um and then wanted to try and
take it further take it forward put it
in the hands of the
standards committee um i said we we put
something
forward it wasn't the complaint it was
really me asking you
is this worthy of looking at and um you
know how do we proceed from here
if we decided to um this
may not be a question that's directly
linked to this but it was something that
i had trouble with at a time
as a new member if something happened
happened
how would i proceed to sort of find out
more
you would go you would go and inquire of
the mod
that would be your um i think the
correct route
she would be able to advise you um
on action from there uh and if she was
concerned she would call in
i think the independent member and
review it together
thank you my is that what you would uh
suggest stacey yeah that's correct chair
i mean i
always advise um to try and
settle in formally if possible and but
if you can't do that if you submit the
details of the complaints
um to me then i review that
um also give the um
subject matter the option to respond to
that complaint
in full um and then i discuss it with
the independent person
as to um what to do
um whether to take it further whether
it's orienting a
referral to standards committee um
i've got um a protocol actually
councillor hawkins if you'd like me to
email that that fruity but
it is on our website as well so
yeah thank you
thank you number two stacy councils
should include provisions in their code
of conduct requiring councillors to
comply with any formal standards
investigation
and prohibiting trivial or malicious
allegations against councillors
that that's not currently within our
code of conduct
right well members
what do you think
i think we should include it
and counselor brenton uh yes but i would
i would yes by all means include it
um but add on the end uh politically
motivated because
as though it says um trivial malicious
malicious
it can also be uh from my own experience
politically motivated
and that should be included as well i've
never had a complaint against me by the
public they've all been
from a political source right
right members of the committee do you
have any views there or are you happy
to have it included um
with uh the political element
yeah that's fine yep
stacy do you want to just note that or
would you want a vote taken on something
like that
so are members minded to review and
update that the code of conduct
with a view to because i i can obviously
include
conclude that if you make the decision
that you'd like to review and update our
current code of conduct
yes i would propose we do review it okay
i'll say
that okay right the members but
uh we'll have individual votes here
because of course they're all going to
be
going to be different um right can we go
to the vote please
thank you chair councillor brenton
board councillor clark or
councillor ford or
councillor hawkins
councillor laws or councillor pennington
is yeah i'm here
sorry there you go apologies for being
late
um i am aware of all the debate before
i'm reading the
situation now four
thank you that's unanimous chair thank
you
all right then stacy yeah just okay
would you
like me to bring forward to the next
standards any any recommendations that
members
make as we go through the list of best
practice today
so if i um submit our current code of
conduct we'll track changes the members
can see the proposals from today's
committee
um and discuss them at the next standard
is that is that how you'd like i'll give
you
give people time to think digest and
uh perhaps amend further council afford
thanks chair yeah just going back
earlier
to councillor brenton really make this
very simple
and you know i'm saying it is simple but
to make it simple
we only need to be flagged up what is
not included
at the moment anything that's not
included there's a hint in the title
best practice
we should include it anyway so i would
actually suggest we include everything
where i've got a concern is always is
actually we don't enforce anything and i
still can't
concerned it's a bit like the signage
then or my apple slip way it's not good
having a sign if you don't read it
but there you go um
yes i hear what you say i'm not inclined
to rubber stamp everything that comes in
an envelope
but uh we'll just go through them and
just see where we end up
but yeah stacy i think to review it the
next committee will be good
right next item please these principal
authorities should review their code of
conduct
each year and regularly seek where
possible the views of the public
community organizations and neighbouring
authorities
um we don't necessarily review it every
year
um obviously the last review was august
2018
and we don't go out and publicly consult
on our code of conduct
um in relation to the neighboring
authorities i do have meetings with the
other devon
um monitoring officers and we were
thinking about bringing in one code of
conduct for devon
so that it was consistent across the
board um
but that because of covid we've we've
not met for
for a while and most of that has been
put on hold
um but i don't know what members think
about um consulting generally on our
code
um and and obtaining other views on our
code of conduct
uh councillor pennington is that linked
to the um
devolution and joining together in our
authorities um to have one call of
conduct across the whole county in the
event
that uh we joined together with other
authorities in years to come
no councillor pendleton it wasn't it was
just felt easier
because if there was a conflict of
interest or you needed another
monitoring officer to step into your
authority
um it would be easier to have one code
of conduct across the board
i mean effectively they're all fairly
broadly similar but
but slightly different i mean they've
all got the same principles under
underlying effectively because it's all
followed by the
nolan principles thank you chair thank
you stacey
we have no other comments there my own
comment is i think
your line it's good i was just going to
suggest that we did just consult with
our neighbors
so that we we were
broadly in sync but it sounds as if
you've gone beyond that
so i think we can just accept for
the next one so an authorities code
should be readably
accessible to both councillors and the
public in a prominent position
on the council's website and available
in council's premises
um we effectively do that i mean it is
published on our website
it's attached to our constitution um i
don't think i've
had a complaint that um that no one's
been able to access our code
thank you just happy with that
local of best practice five local
authorities should update their
gifts and hospitality register at least
once a quarter
and publish it in accept an accessible
format
um we don't update it once a quarter
um we ask members to
um let us know if there's been any
change and we'll update it at that stage
but i wouldn't necessarily go out to all
members and say can you update
every quarter i think most members know
that
it's sent out it's completed and um
to let us know all democratic services
know of any update
and it is published yeah i'm not sure
that i've ever had a reminder saying
are you up to date i may have but i
can't recall
seeing you i canceled pennington what
does csv stand for for
people like me who should know but don't
apologize
don't apologize come to pennington
because i have no idea either
it's called comma separated values thank
you very much indeed
it's the way you hold the data
yeah that comes as a great relief
members
uh good could i ask
what would we do without counsellor
clark here
i'm very worried one day you're not
going to appear
one of these days could i ask chair at
this stage then
how big is the current register
of gifts and hospitality do do we have
many members who have to declare this
such things
or is it a very small item
two questions there all members are
required to declare
a gift i think it's about 20 pounds of
the limit at the moment isn't it
stacey
sorry 25 pounds or above
right yes i was aware of that chair but
i wondered
how many members actually receive his
hospitality
and need to declare it right
um
i received a paperback book last year
which i declared
but i've not had any i've got
no experience of of the actual
hospitality
i don't know of other members have um
but it's for them to declare it
really sorry counselor pennington
yeah just to say i've only had one i
think in my own time and that was a
meal before the football match a bit of
a football ground
and uh plymouth or gaia were playing
there as well so i had to declare it but
i've never had 25 pounds worth i'm
waiting for
25 pounds
[Laughter]
but my accountant will probably tackle
and declare that as a
income as well when i come to do my tax
returns so i really wanted thank you
well chair it would seem to me that as a
not a very large
um matter updating once a quarter seems
to be
rather too frequent yes i
would have presumed it would be done
annually um
uh obviously they must have found
instances where it should have been
you know there was a need to but uh
i i personally can't see anything
annually is
is good enough but i do think we
if we don't we should send out a
reminder once a year
to to bring your um particulars up to
date
right next one council should publish a
clear and straightforward public
interest test against which allegations
are filtered
we don't do that at the moment it would
be helpful i
i i do agree with that
well members has anybody got any views
there
okay sorry uh councillor ford
yeah thanks chair um quickly uh this
one's quite important because karen but
actually going back to the last one
all of this relies on people being
honest and unfortunately quite a lot of
counselors probably struggle with that
quite frankly the illness is on yourself
to actually declare something and it
could actually be very important at the
time
if the council for instance was involved
in for instance which i'm not i'm just
plucking it a thing either a planet
thing or a covenant or whatever which
has got
financial implications if there's a
councillor that's actually
uh got his nose in the cross from one of
the parties
he's duty by the declaring that and go
in the next day or whatever
surely you know i'm sorry it's time to
actually people being honest and
unfortunately my experience quite a lot
aren't
but carrying on to actually best
practice six very important
because i will be taken to two cancers
of tasks and i don't mind it but this is
in part one in those
uh youtube or whoever's listening i
won't name the package
please i won't name anybody i won't
usually that's
fine because we are getting a part i
will just stick it i have got a level 8
law
right i'm just going to the fifth of
this month in a a journal
so it has got public interest this is
why it's relevant
let from a robin julian uh not normally
of my political persuasion
but good letter from in the journal
reference
the case that we've just had which cost
the
taxpayer a lot of money two counselors
they know where they are and the public
interest ought to go forward
i have sent an email around or if not
we'll be doing so
i'm sorry because it casts a shadow on
other members and with that i'll leave
it but i am not laughing and it's
serious now we're dealing with it
i think you can support chancellor
pennington
yeah very similar really um
we've all got interest and we need a bar
to abide by which we
are clear whether we're over that bar or
not i mean we got elected because we
were involved in our communities
um and we've got links in so many ways
and
and it is a really dangerous area that
we are into
when we are serving our communities
because we live our lives here
and particularly private citizens in one
sense
are are good but when you run businesses
like
i do myself it's surprising how
wide and how far you know people and and
what the public perception is
it's about public perception when it
comes to the day
and and it is a really dangerous area
um and i would welcome any further
guidance um
that clearly defines where that level is
i think and that would be my point chair
thank you see can i just
ask you are filtered
how do you do that
the last words it's not easy
actually um and that's why
we've got the independent person um
i'm really pleased to say um it's very
rare that
i've received a serious complaint it it
usually is you know forgive me for
saying
gripes or kind of personal disputes
between people
yeah um i've not had
an extremely serious complaint um
thankfully
and since i've been monitoring officer
um but that's how we filter we've got an
independent person who's entirely
independent of the process
um and obviously chair if we had
a really serious allegation i'd discuss
it with you as well to see
i think that's really important because
a lot of these complaints are very
subjective
and quite often it's very hard to get to
the bottom of what's gone on
that you know there's no evidence
there's no witnesses it's usually a
dispute between
one person to another and and and as as
you know with complaints
um those two parties have very different
um perceptions of the event
all right councillor ford yeah uh just
briefly chair um and i'll own up i don't
know exactly whether it's covered here
or not but stacy certainly would do
actually obviously knows the job a lot
better than i know or a job and write
yourself
um i do find occasionally
where counselors dare i say it abuse
their position
therefore going to a big gripe they
might have a gripe against another
counselor or
a member of public and actually abuse
their
privilege and position um sometimes
might be difficult to prove but is there
anything
in here that actually refers to that or
or whereby
at least you know um reminds people of
that because i could actually name two
or three i ain't gonna do but i'm sorry
it happens
i'm not not very impressed with it
cheers
yes i mean it is difficult because if
we're gonna go into
into the nitty-gritty of this instead of
having bet best practice up to whatever
number it
is uh number 14 we'd have
best practice up to number 240
we so many um there is a
there is a reliance on members to
declare things and to be honest and
and if if we start delving too deeply
and throwing stones we're going to end
up not with the good counsel i'm afraid
anyway can i come in chair there yeah
definitely thank you
the item six chair is really not
particularly about
about counsellor's behavior it's really
addressed to how
the monitoring officer would decide
which
complaints should be handled and which
should be filtered out
on a public interest basis that's the
issue here
not council's behaviour it's a clear and
straightforward public interest test
against which allegations are filtered
now
it may be an allegation comes in which
the mo
says actually it's not in the public
interest for me to spend three days and
involve external lawyers
pursuing this one and that's what number
six is all about
it's not about the council's behavior
particularly
right cancer pennington uh thank you
chair going back to council ford's
comment again
i would agree with him um and in the
negative area
in which we operate about this public
interest test
because one is aware where a counselor
dislikes
somebody and you wonder um why now we
have to declare
um in the public interest where we have
a strong relationship
in favor of somebody um but we don't
have to declare
the reverse situation and uh i
i i do find that happens occasionally
um and you know i go to several parish
meetings and
sometimes particularly at paris level
there is access to be ground it seems to
me
and um i just uh wonder
all to do at that level of discussion
uh the negative side uh not only the the
positive side
thank you chair yes
it is difficult uh because it does come
down to a human being now monitoring
officer
to look in the first instance and uh
especially at the moment with kovit
everybody's a little bit more on edge
and allegations are easily thrown around
may i say especially on zoom if you're
sat
facing somebody face to face i think
you're probably
a little better behaved a little more
polite
but there we are that uh that is what it
is the next one i find concerning
because stacy do we have
two independent people did we have
anybody come forward at
all no unfortunately not and
i i think we would agree that we should
have at least two independent people
we've advertised four times i think and
and and not had any interest in the
position
so we are uh we have one and martin
rules
um who's very good and very helpful but
i i sometimes think
especially when i've got a lot of
complaints that it's really unfair
on him because he's getting quite a lot
to deal with although
you know give him he's not not
complained himself about about that but
um no i don't know what else to do i
think we agreed at the last standards
we'd go out and advertise again for
another independent person
um and and we haven't had any luck
right well what we can do is to
keep trying regularly just place place
and advertisement
uh well in these times when there's very
few reporters around
doing much reporting perhaps if you did
a press release
uh with a picture of your good self
explaining how
important it was that members of public
should
monitor what cancers do in the council
and that um
we're seeking people rather than putting
an advert in which probably a lot of
people don't look
but they do look at the little
newsprints because we would have to do
the news uh
um release but we got a couple of
officers down there very good at uh
doing that sort of thing
you have a picture of yourself bloody
black you know whatever
now that's uh i think that's um a good
idea
uh i mean people are all too keen to
point the thing
and say oh that council's not doing its
job properly
uh this is their opportunity the public
spirited to come forward perhaps they
just don't read all these small adverts
perhaps we put that forward uh states
perhaps the management
uh committee to to consider it
that's a really good idea i i i think
that's a really really good idea
um so we can certainly do that yeah
right
counselor pennington uh thank you chair
can you um
stacy or yourself explain um does the
independent members have the right to
vote on decisions because i do remember
reading some minutes in the past of
various issues
when the number of people present and
the votes taken were completely
different and they came out when i
investigated
that the independent members weren't
allowed to vote and it would help
you in your minutes to explain at the
beginning certain people who
cannot vote and who can vote because i
think it puts the committee on a
different
level of power within deciding issues
so clarity if independent members can
and can't vote
um can that be made clear when we're
balancing out the number of people
attending
against the number of votes taken thank
you chair
thank you uh um it's now an honor to ask
councillor
hackett for his views
yes um thank you very much chairman
thank you nick
as well as stacy putting an advert out i
just wondered if
um say mr clark who
expresses himself very well and is very
articulate
if he could put something in the advert
and explain
what he has achieved and why it's so
vital to have these independent members
and put it from a layman's perspective
because some people
you know the general public might think
on occasions oh well
if i if i could say this or if i could
do that well here's their opportunity to
do it and
an independent member can say yes
actually i was in that position and this
is what i've achieved and this is what
the role means to me
and how i can represent the public
and shall we say hold counselors to
account in some ways
for what their actions are it's just a
thought
no yes a good thought too i think
um i'm happy to help out chair if i if
i'm needed um i would just like if if
you don't mind me to say
that um when one talks about independent
members
we don't have independent members
anymore we have an independent person
and it's a rather different role from
what the old independent man in fact a
very different role
from what the independent members used
to have years ago
but if the officers whose job it is to
write this press release
would like my help i'm happy to give it
thank you thank you right
number eight when i asked about my
question chair
um about the independent member's right
to vote you went straight to coaster
hackett before i
respond from the the the solicitor
i am sorry i'm stacy can you uh
i can't um yeah they don't vote and
as mr clark said it is an independent
person not a member so
it's committee members that vote
independent person does have a very
separate role
there are check and balance when it
comes um to complaints that are
submitted against counsellors
and the good thing about it is they are
entirely independent of the council and
can look at it from the outside
perspective and and more
as though a member of the public or
anybody so that that that's their role
entirely independent from torridge the
council or any other process
which is a good check and balance when a
complaint has come through and i find it
really helpful i'm sure um
counsellors would find it really helpful
if they've got a complaint against them
to have someone outside
our whole process
yeah but would help just if we recorded
in the minutes when
you're reading minutes and you do see a
discrepancy between
those attending and the number of votes
taken an explanation so
when members of the public go back over
previous minutes
um you understand why there is the
difference between the two
numbers yeah we we can certainly note
that in the minutes councilor pennington
thank you very much thank you i think
number eight we adhere to
don't we yes we certainly do
yep so we we refer all complaints to uh
the independent person for them to
review
oh
number nine then where a local authority
makes a decision
on an allegation of misconduct following
a formal investigation
a decision noted should be published as
soon as possible on its website
including a brief statement of facts the
provisions of the
encode engaged by the allegations the
view of the independent person
and the reasoning of the decision maker
together with any sanctioned applied
this isn't within our code of conduct at
the moment
i mean my own personal view is i don't
particularly want it in there either but
that's uh i think it could be used
almost as
a mischief-making tool but um members do
you have a view
they're speechless daisy i said too much
already chair and i don't normally
attend this meeting so
no um no um
angela pennington it's good to have you
here
you normally have good common sense
views i don't always agree with them
but uh um no please if anyone has any
views please speak
trying to hello chancellor brandon
yes i i don't have a problem with this
at all um
i think it's good that we're supposed to
be an open
and uh accountable body set
i don't think there's any uh problem
with doing that providing of course it's
uh it's properly balanced the actual
reporting thereof
and thereby analyze the problem i think
it's because
it's you can read these two ways very
often and
and it's not as easy as one would think
for um stacy or a monitoring officer to
put
this together but there so members do
you want it included
chair i would like to strike out about
including the view of the independent
person
the independent person view should be
something that they're not going to be
held account to
later on i think i think it would be
wrong
in case that independent person differed
from
the committee as a whole i think that
would that would undermine their
position completely
in one way though that's taking away the
strength of it the
fact that an independent person has
looked
but there yeah i can understand
your point of view and
yeah stacy do you have any views on this
at all yourself oh sorry councillor ford
yeah briefly uh chair um yeah actually
just pick up on that last point
uh about the independent person it's
like this they
you know i have mentioned before how
independent independent impersonators
provided they are
i think it's a great check and balance
but also
is there an initial institution that
would actually actually
further any allegation anyway you know
it's a serious role
so whether the outcome differs a bit or
whatever
i do think they do need to put their
head above the parapet
and you know it's just you as well and
you're right about checking balance
um i've got no problem with things being
part of paper because
you know i've been before the community
before and you know
and like yourself was phone guilty of
calling a cancer hypocrite even though
it's factually accurate so i've got no
problem with being reported when i do
you know whatever i say rightly or
wrongly i'm quite people not being in
the press
right um right stacy did you have a view
on this one
i think it needs to be clarified what i
mean after an investigation
i i i would agree that if there's a
formal standards committee hearing and a
decision is made by that committee
that that should be published um
and i i know council brenton stated
before actually standard committee's
hearing should be in public as well
so if you've had a hearing in public um
and then
that decision that should be i i think
it should be
posted i i'm not sure i agree that all
informal
all formal investigations should be
published because
sometimes the outcome of that is that no
further action should be taken
um but if it was a formal standards
hearing i think that that's right that
it should be published and i think
that's one of the standards committee's
sanctions fair enough
right i don't know whether i'm all in
favor of actually having it in public
because you can
tarnish somebody's reputation
yeah um right so
are we going to look for including that
do you want to dwell on it to the next
meeting
no
we want it included or not counselor
clark
uh no i i i think we should um
give ourselves more time to look at the
actual wording before we make a decision
personally a bit with stacey on this
that
you know if if we've got an open meeting
that's in the public eye then it doesn't
matter because
we can publish it because it's it's it's
been in the public eye anyway
people are open now on youtube to watch
us
you know and if we've got a standards
meeting that people have come to
in the town hall then it's an open
meeting so there's no reason not to
publish
that result but i think if something is
uh
that we're looking at in a more serious
manner than we
before we we destroy
somebody we should you know look at it
more seriously so i would i would like
to put it off and
and revisit this if it's possible yeah i
agree with that chair
if you had a case where there were two
members who
had a disagreement and if you like the
monitoring officer spoke to them both
they were both embarrassed that they
used bad language
they were ashamed of themselves they
apologized to each other
shook hands if we were allowed to and
said it wouldn't happen again
i don't think we actually do any good
by putting that in public domain
thank you right we'll we'll leave it
there um stacy and just mark it
for further review later right
where are we now number 10
a local authority should have
straightforward accessible guidance
on its website to make a as to how to
make a complaint under the code of
conduct
the process for handling complaints and
estimated
time skills for investigations and
outcomes
um the majority of that is there um we
do try and deal with complaints
fairly swiftly um time skills for
investigations and outcomes i
that's that's a hard one um depending on
upon the nature of the allegation and
the amount of people
um involved um
and clearly if a matter did go to a
hearing
we are in the cycle of committees so
you know i i always do try and and and
deal with them as swiftly as possible
um although not saying much
recently it's been quite difficult but
yes but i mean
i'm in favor of it we just strike out
that last uh
that last piece on timescale sorry
councillor ford
um yeah just uh briefly uh
another problem we've had here in in the
past as well
is any system should be made as easy as
possible for the public
to access and to put in complaints after
all we are public servants and people
very often i think we've you know there
are some that forget that we already
serve
the general public at large not our
personal friends or buddies
now we're i could quote example i won't
but i know it could be the case
there was a complaint against a
councillor which probably probably
should have went further but the person
was scared about
recommendations if they actually
put the case forward so is there any way
that you can actually reassure people
that it won't get we we can have it
we can emulate nations and whatever
couldn't say the word but you know they
are worried about
councillors therefore again abusing
their power or making their life
difficult
um and that's not exaggeration chair
that actually has happened locally
cheers
well
i don't know what to say about that at
all
i don't think
i don't think we can cover that
circumstance can we
i mean it's uh we have to be open
um we can't keep somebody hidden away
because
it is what it is i mean we're going into
great depths there
do you have a view stacy
i think it's i can understand councillor
um ford's
point um but if you flip it
to the other side um if people can make
anonymous complaints
then that's very hard to deal with and i
i always say when complainants come
forward and the counselor concerned is
entitled to see the full complaint and
respond to it
and if it was a a very serious one
and it went forward to a standards
committee
that evidence is entitled to be tested
in front of the standards committee
so i can't see a way that we can deal
with it anonymously without the
counsellor knowing
um and if it was anonymous the other
difficulty is
you know you could just have vexatious
complaints against counsellors again
um you know they want to make a
complaint they've really got to stick
their name to it unfortunately
that's been my opinion and previously
i've not accepted anonymous complaints
i don't think you should either but then
my counselor forward again please yeah
just briefly don't
don't this wasn't exactly anonymous i
won't go into the case but actually it's
reported by someone else
not the person affected witnessed by
several other people
quite a serious issue but basically i
think because of the
the lady in question did not want to
pursue it i did not
feel safe that she could pursue it
basically same old thing
nothing was done and just a bit of
tongue-in-cheek i've mentioned this
before
if we ever got any surplus cash in the
kitty at times which is unlikely over
several years
i'd be quite happy to be wired up to a
lie detector i think that's something we
need to do actually for all coasters are
actually wired up
cheers well there we are i'm glad that
was
tongue-in-cheek be quiet from now on
about my fair share today
right okay right
so what are we going to do then uh um uh
what's the view of the council is on
this one
do we have any of you which we just
accept it
yeah i'm happy enough right next stacy
number 12 monitoring officer roles
should include providing advice
support and management of investigations
and adjudications on alleged breaches to
parish councils
within the remit of the principal
authority they should be
they should provide be provided with
adequate training corporate support
and resources to undertake this work
well we do don't we is that
i i give as much support as i can i mean
it's really difficult um
especially at the moment because we've
got 64 parishes
um and if we were to
adequately provide all of that including
training and corporate support and
resources um
it would cost us you know heavily
a lot of the time the parish councils
wouldn't want that sort of involvement
um but i i do um
obviously get involved with member
complaints in
parish councils um
but it is a big task and that's
something that i'm going to come on to
later in relation to complaints i mean
you're
always available to advise we're a small
authority
i could imagine this in a large
authority
being being more of an issue but here
you're available to advise them and
that's the main thing
i think oh sorry councillor pennington
yeah
thank you um i'm really concerned about
the parish level
um simply because many of the councils
are no longer elected they come to an
agreement and co-opted onto the council
um i think it's only about a dozen um
parishes
actually had elections in may of 2019 so
um
you know people put their name forward
now are getting less and less
and i think if you put too much emphasis
then people aren't going to put their
names forward even more
and that does concern me at democracy at
the very basic level
um within our community
all right
is everybody happy yeah yeah
we always happy chair right
right then um next one stacy
local authorities should have procedures
in place to address any conflicts of
interest
when undertaking a standards
investigation
possible step should include asking the
monitoring officer
from a different authority to undertake
the investigation
um that would happen anyway as a matter
of course
if it was something to give it the
independent
um view and and actually if it happened
at one of our committees and i was there
for instance i think it would only be
correct that somebody independent
witnessed sorry reviewed the
the the investigation yeah
so recovered there that's fine
getting near the end going too smoothly
for this right
next next one stacy council should
report on separate bodies they have set
up with
or which they own as part of their
annual government statement and give a
full picture of their relationship with
those bodies
separate bodies created by local
authorities should abide by the nolan
principles of openness
and publish their border genders and
minutes and annual reports in an
accessible place
we have the scrutiny committees and and
um
separate parties that we work with will
go to external
ons and report and then sometimes
internal ons as well yeah
members find me that yes
how many bodies do we have chair that we
set up then
um i don't honestly know
not only have we if we don't have any
it's irrelevant
plus is one chair that i can think of
okay harbour board yeah hoverboard
uh i wouldn't class that as a separate
body that that
that's torridge it is
the fact that we've got one it's not
going to hurt to leave it in there
we will comply anyway
15
[Applause]
senior officers should meet regularly
with political group leaders or group
whips to discuss
standard issues
i think i think chair this need only
applied
when necessary i don't think you need a
regular
meeting just sat there staring at one
another so
not a not a pretty sight so i think uh
just as as when required yeah
so i think we're there on those days see
you happy there
so i'll um
do some amendments to our current code
of conduct
and i'll do it in track changes and i'll
bring it forward to the the next
committee and then if there's any other
suggestions because we've got time with
this
um then we can discuss the next
standards committee
well the members can pick it up off of
the uh the minutes and just give
give some further uh further thought
uh right members um number seven forward
plan
that's on page 13 of your agenda
right i don't know whether anybody has
uh anything they feel
should come forward i'm i'm just
very frustrated by the fact that we have
no
sanctions and we're almost dreaming up i
mean not in this case today
but items to put there does anybody have
any
specifics
is there anything stacy that you feel
would be
obviously we've got to review the best
practice again there
yeah well we can review the code of
conduct and
our hearing procedures i can bring them
forward as well it would seem
um sensible to review it all at the same
time and see if
um there's any comments in relation to
how we
uh conduct our investigations um and
conduct our standards committee hearing
so if
if we do get any which i'm hoping that
we don't we are ready to go
yeah yeah uh
right is everybody happy there then yes
right at this point we'll have to say
goodbye to our members of our
members of the public because we need to
now go into
uh part two um
i'm prepared to move that do i have a
second to go into part two please
thank you can we go to the vote please
thank you chair councillor brenton or
councillor clark for councillor ford
or councillor hawkins or
councillor laws or councillor pennington
fresh unanimous chair thank you